[Music]
we concluded the previous video with a
new term it's called the human dentition
any idea what it could mean something
related to teeth I know but what exactly
is it let's understand the definition of
human dentition first it's defined as
the study of the teeth pattern and their
functions in humans okay so what we've
been studying so far is dentition
somewhat yes we have studied a few
concepts related to teeth and now we
learn a few more technically dentition
is the characteristic arrangement kind
and number of teeth in a given species
at a given age that means in a
particular species how the teeth are
arranged what are the characteristic
features of those teeth like the size
shape and so on and also how many teeth
in total are present is what the
dentition tells us can you tell me how
many teeth do V humans have the instant
answer we give is 32 but is that really
the case with all let's find that out
humans like other mammals are diffident
and what does that mean deaf ear don't
in simple words means having two sets of
teeth and does that refer to the teeth
on both upper and the lower jaws nope
absolutely not humans have two sets of
teeth one is the deciduous and the other
is the permanent set of teeth now what
are these exactly we know that a few
months after birth a set of teeth begin
to appear in the baby these teeth are
called the baby teeth or the milk teeth
or the primary or even the deciduous
teeth after these teeth fall away the
next set of permanent teeth begin to
appear so the primary and then the
permanent are the two sets of teeth in
the life of humans due to which we are
called diffident and what's the number
of these teeth
well the
teeth are usually training number and
the growth of the entire set of these
teeth is generally completed by the time
a child is 2 or 3 years old the next set
of permanent teeth that starts
developing is at around 5 years of age
the training milk teeth are later
replaced by around 30 to permanent teeth
yes the 32 teeth that we usually talk
about now can you tell me the number of
each type of teeth is it fixed or random
it's definitely fixed and how is that
determined you will be surprised to know
that there are formulae to understand
the dentition pattern in different
animals including humans yes they are
called the dental formulae the number
and the arrangement of the teeth in the
human's form the human dental formula
for an adult human mouth
the dental formula is given as 2 1 2 3
by 2 1 2 3 and how is that read take
this representation for example here
let's focus on the upper jaw first here
if we divide the complete jaw in equal
halves
we get two incisors one canine two
premolars and three molars so this makes
up 8 teeth on one side of the upper jaw
same is the case with the other half yes
2 1 2 3 so 8 and 8 give us 16 teeth in
the upper jaw now what about the lower
jaw if we carefully count then the lower
jaw also has two incisors one canine
two premolars and three molars so here
is well we get sixteen teeth in total
and together we get thirty-two teeth on
adding the ones from both jaws since we
have two incisors one canine two
premolars and three molars on both upper
and lower jaws on each side we write the
formula as two one two three by two one
two three now here we have an image of
an infant mouth with primary or the milk
teeth can you tell me the dental formula
for this arrangement
okay let me give you a hint there are in
total twenty milk teeth in infants now
try cracking this interesting question
and do leave your answers in the comment
section below
[Music]
you